I have to talk to you about this scam
deal that Donald Trump did with carrier
and its parent company United
Technologies now the background is
already a major scam the big news was
I'm Trump I negotiated that carrier will
keep a thousand jobs in Indianapolis
instead of moving them to Mexico in and
of itself it was already a scam because
there was there was a plan to move 2,000
jobs from Indiana to Mexico meaning that
Trump's major negotiations and giving
millions of dollars to carrier still was
going to lead to a thousand of those
2000 jobs going to Mexico in addition
what Donald Trump did is a completely
unsustainable solution you can't just go
and negotiate with every company and
give the money and it's the opposite of
a free market solution because it does
not change anything fundamentally about
the business environment in which we are
operating just going to a company and
saying here take money to stay but we've
now learned that it is an even bigger
scam than I thought and believe me I
thought it was a pretty damn big scam
number one it turns out that the
thousand jobs that were going to be kept
in Indianapolis or maybe it was supposed
to be 1,100 doesn't matter because it's
not that big it's 750 Union jobs
according to the media communications
rep who commented on CNN earlier today
named TJ TJ Bray he said we were told it
would be a thousand or 1,100 jobs gonna
be 750 Union jobs that are actually
being kept here but here is where it
really gets completely nuts Greg Hayes
is the CEO of United Technologies that's
the parent company of carrier he
admitted that this deal that Donald
Trump struck with them will ultimately
lead to fewer jobs in Indiana why I mean
you can't write this stuff Pat by
keeping the plant in Indiana for now uh
that gives carrier more money to do
stuff with and as a result of the deal
that Trump made carrier is going to
start a 16 million dollar investment to
drive down the cost
of production in order to reduce the
cost gap with operating in Mexico in
other words it's much cheaper to run the
business in Mexico but carrier with the
money Trump is giving them that Trump is
having the government give them they are
going to invest the money in driving
down the cost of production in the
United States how are they going to do
that automation what does that mean that
Trump's big victory is going to lead to
jobs being replaced by machines this is
a transcript from CNBC's show Mad Money
with Jim Cramer
and Greg Hayes said right well and again
if you think about what we talked about
last week we're going to make a 16
million dollar investment in that
Factory in Indianapolis to automate to
drive the cost down so that we can
continue to be competitive now is it as
cheap as moving to Mexico with lower
cost of labor no but we will make that
plant competitive just because we'll
make the capital investments there Jim
Cramer says right - which Greg Hayes
adds but what that ultimately means is
there will be fewer jobs that's right
carrier is taking the money that they
got in this major successful negotiation
that Trump did and putting it into
automating away the American jobs that
Trump is taking credit for saving this
is the biggest scam sham freak show of
smoke and mirrors from Donald Trump that
we've seen so far in his very early
tenure currently just President Elect
it's a total sham yeah we've long
suspected that this would just kind of
be a victory on optics and you're only
saving $1,000 thousand jobs to begin
with yet now it seems that those jobs
are gonna end up being replaced anyway
by automation and it really just goes
the point that people get so upset with
their jobs going to low-wage workers in
developing countries right really
they're they're they're targeting the
wrong enemy they're absolutely Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton neither of
them talking about job out automation is
a serious problem during 2016 campaign
yeah keep the jobs here move them to
Mexico or not we won they won it's
making America great again they're
investing the money in replacing the
jobs with machines everyone
from the liberal economist Paul Krugman
to Republican senator Ben Sasse is
regularly discussing the undeniable
reality that technological developments
are a much bigger threat to American
workers than trade even though Donald
Trump has been super successful at
making trade the enemy and the people
that voted for Trump thinking that he's
going to bring jobs back that have left
uh are operating under the assumption
that that's possible
that's only even possible in the short
term if Trump just starts giving money
to companies to keep jobs in the United
States in a completely anti free-market
way at taxpayer expense by the way it is
a total and utter joke smoke and mirrors
is actually what the reality of Trump
so-called victories are it's starting to
really get into the thick of the holiday
gift buying season and at at this point
I basically refuse to go and stand in
lines at malls fight people for parking
spots get into arguments about whether
I'm over the line or somebody else is in
that parking lot so when it comes to
watches I prefer to check out movement
watches on the Internet
I have a movement watch and I love it
everywhere I go people ask me about it
what's that watch that's really cool and
the best part about it is people see
movement watches and they assume not
incorrectly if you're used to department
store pricing that they must be four or
five hundred dollar watches but they're
not they look like they are but actually
they start at just ninety five dollars
and you can actually get 15% off plus
free shipping plus free returns by going
to envy empty watches dot-com / Pakman
clean designs great movements and
started by two guys with a Kickstarter
campaign IndieGoGo campaign much like
the David Pakman show
who thought we want cool watches but we
don't want them to have to cost 400 to
500 dollars you can go to NV empty
watches dot-com slash Pakman save 15%
free returns free shipping